[Applaudissements]
ces jours de musique aux jardins de
lakota pauvres et peut-être québec et on
a trouvé le moyen de contourner le
problème du confinement
[Musique]
et
les policiers et des pompiers sont aussi
venus pour saluer le travail du
personnel à cette résidence pour
personnes âgées petite fenêtre de
bonheur pour ces résidents qui sont
confinés comme ailleurs depuis plus de
40 jours
j'ai pas eu le temps de me préparer j'ai
dû faire face à la machine et je prenais
les émissions de monsieur logo du
premier ministre est là c'était toujours
les petits lieux des petites vieilles
alors là j'ai pris conscience tout à
coup que j'étais lent d'une petite
vieille
[Musique]
get chevalier à 78 officiellement dans
sa tête elle en a 32 mois en temps
normal le l'ancienne mairesse de sainte
anne de beaupré conduit sa voiture et
s'implique dans plusieurs organismes la
crise sanitaire actuelle l'a grandement
affecté je l'avais plus de goût manger
j'avais pu gouttes réveiller c'était de
m'étendre sur le divin puis d'écouter la
télévision lorsqu'elle ce virus rend
dans une résidence pour aînés
c'est un peu comme mettre le feu dans le
foin tout brûle rapidement dans la
région de montréal
et puis centre canadien de la pandémie
le moral est bas même dans les
résidences ou l'aco vide n'a pas encore
frappé
jacques rintintin qu'est un migrant
diaries begin et que je reçois des gens
et moi j'ai déjà dit ça fait que c'est
elle permet de gommer béchat les couples
les nouvelles dans ce monde entier des
énigmes normale sup et ça peu précipité
l'apparition de symptômes dépressifs de
symptômes anxieux et chez des personnes
qui ont déjà eu ces symptômes là dans le
passé mais qui sont sous contrôle
ça peut les exacerber donc s'appeler où
les aggraver et ça peut même aggraver
les symptômes au niveau des pertes de
mémoire chez ces personnes
j'ai des très bonnes amies très bons
amis sont disparus ce sam arraché le
coeur mais
robert tremblay réside depuis 15 ans ou
ch et celle des notre dame de la merci
dans le nord de montréal où plus du
quart des 325 résidents sont infectés il
dit ne pas se sentir en danger puisque
les employés disposent tous des
équipements de protection nécessaires
c'est plutôt le confinement absolue
qu'il a du mal à supporter cet ancien
militaire ne peut plus voir sa femme ni
commandé ces petits plats préférés
c'est une épine munitions juger mais je
me lève deux fois par semaine le
mercredi et samedi
parce que je me fais qu'il avait les
cheveux un bon élève à vos agendas
[Musique]
jouant
les gériatres recommande aux personnes
âgées confiné de s'efforcer de bouger et
de pratiquer une activité de loisir mais
ce n'est pas possible pour tous et des
problèmes de santé plus graves sont à
prévoir
tôt ou tard quand le déconfinement des
aînés surviendra ya beaucoup de
personnes qui sont en laisse et a laissé
tout seul ça va peut-être aussi aggravé
certains problèmes médicaux qui aurait
peut-être dû être pris en charge plus
tôt
[Musique]
je suis un confinement et le plus dur
c'est de l'accepter et je peux vous dire
que je les accepte maintenant mais je
voudrais pas que ça prenne encore si
moore
[Musique]